On the QuantDesk platform,
we can backtest in exactly the same way.
Go over here to the BackTest tab and
click on Forecast.
And again, we can configure which group
of stocks are we going to work with,
and what are the settings for
our backtest.
For instance,
how much money do we start with?
How frequently do we want to trade,
over what period of time do we want
to run the backtest and so on.
Anyway, we make those selections.
We also need to choose parameters for
the forecaster.
Again, which model do we want to use,
which includes what are the factors
that we're paying attention to.
How far into the future do we
want to make our forecast and
how much data looking
back do we want to use.
Once we make all those selections,
we can click on BackTest and
it'll start running.
It takes quite a bit of time,
so we're going to go ahead and
process in the background.
And I'll show you what one of
these backtests looks like.
Here's an example report
their system generates.
This is again for a forecast backtest.
The orange line here represents
the historical value of our portfolio.
The blue is the benchmark that
we're using, which is S&P 500.
You can see here a number
of metrics tabulated
over this period of time
we saw 346% return.
Our sharp ratio was 1.14 and so on.
So this is just an example of the kinds
of systems you can build using
the sorts of things we
teach you in this class.
So that's the forecast backtest.